A.
Přejeme.
Tome houdo vezmeme to jako 1 no jo mi
chválně poprosil jestli bys mohl mít 1
páč máš nějakou schůzku nebo něco?
Jo jo jo jo jo jestli chceš teďka nějak
začít? Jo jo, jo, určitě souhlasí to.
Souhlasí jo.
Souhlasí.
Ještě vydržuju kuč jo.
Jasný.
Ano.
Jsou všichni ten Radek Plzeň.
Dobrot tak my jsme tady.
Teda, případně ve stationu jinak a já.
Tak budeme rádi,
když se přijdete za ráme dolů nebo nahoru,
to je 1.
Tak týdenní dobré odpoledne,
jinak je zpátky po doledani.
Dneska bychom vzali teda.
KPI.
Je že spíš nějakej shade FKPI sharif.
KPI bychom projeli a potom standardně
bychom šli na agendu těch projektů.
Nějak vnímám,
že jsme toho docela hodně událo,
hodně diskutovalo,
tak si řekneme a případně my.
Se kdo ta?
Web na nějaký detaily,
který mě asi teďka napadají.
Jak se vás na ně vlastně zeptat tohle
grémium?
Tak já teda promítnu.
Promítnuté nejdřív ty KPI ještě.
Tak.
Tak pojďme na to.
1 teda venku chceš?
Chceš něco do sebe krátce ohledně kvality
a.
Ne zajímalo mi.
Ne jo jako co co se týká.
Týká vlastně kvalit produktivity, tak.
Když se podíváš trošku doprava na ten
graf.
Tak je tam jako vidět,
že ta tendence je taková jako víceméně
stabilní,
ale hodně kolísá nahoru dolů to ne.
Já teď nemám zorganizováno,
proč to tak je,
ale vlastně jako produktivita nám ani v 1
baráku v zásadě jako neroste.
Nebo když vyroste,
tak potom poklesne ten trend z dráčanech
se trošku zvednul.
Je tam vidět poměrně hezky tady na tom
grafu, když se podíváme na ty sloupce,
který jsou vlastně jako v pozadí,
tak je vidět ten modrý.
I kvalita ručení ten oranžový je kvalita
expedice, tak je vidět,
že tam se nám to jako přesunulo,
že vlastně na začátku roku jako
převládala,
nebo jsme vlastně doručování doháněli
nekvalitu expedice teď v zásadě jako máme
lepší kvalitu expedice než doručení,
tak to je zajímavej trend,
kterej se tam tý.
Posledním měsíci stál,
teď zase zatím jako neumím říct,
proč jsem to prodiskutoval s 2.
Tohle a případně příští tejden mi bude
zase to měsíční,
tak se na to zkusíme podívat.
Ale jako co se týká produktivity,
tak krásně trochu rostou.
Už nic je taky malinko vzroste,
ale nic jako zásadního se tam nemění a
spíš je to takový jako kolísalý nahoru
dolu no.
Tak jo.
Protože davide něco jako.
Ten dojde davide,
chceš se vyjádřit k chrášťanským datům? K.
Tak tam Tomáš jednoduchý, že jo,
protože se začaly otevírat ty depa nepo
tam maj problémy byly problémy na
východních Čechách a podobně a to ti tu
kvalitu toho doručení.
Teoreticky, no nevím proč ne.
Jo do toho minulý týden jsme tam taky
měli nějaké problémy,
A ta produktivita.
protože jsme pozdě uzavírali nějaké
svazáky na hostín a tak.
A produktivita koukám tak je vlastně jako
spojená s výplatníma termínama,
takže když jsou výplatní termíny,
tak mi ty lidi dokážete zdutelizovat ve
chvíli, kdy je termíny nejsou tak tam.
Tak tam ta úspora s rozhodně.
Tam zase tady u toho tam,
když to řeknu blbě tak minulý týden.
Tak vlastně my jsme se dostali trošičku
do čoudu s příjmem,
takže vlastně tam to nemělo ta efektivita
byla.
To byly prostě utracený hodiny vlastně na
příjmu. Jo,
kde my jsme si z toho minulýho týdne
přenesli prostě větší díl,
že jsme toho míň zpracovali,
než jsme měli,
protože v pondělí jsme začínali ne s
nějakejma,
já nevím plácnu blbost 200 palet jo,
začínali jsme 750.
A my jsme končili.
To tam doháněli doháněli příjem,
kterej se vlastně jako na.
Tak.
Který to má jako.
Tak tak tak tak tak.
To je dobře, no.
OK.
Tak jo.
Tome.
Prosím můžete nebo na obecně na zásobu?
OK co se týče hytrayu,
tak teda standardně nekomentuju.
Tam pořád ještě nemáme správnou metriku.
Co se týče efekt.
Hele já jsem jenom, prosím tě.
Dneska četl nějakou zprávu od lapiho, že?
Telemetrika se upravovat nebude.
Slyšel jsi, mluvil jsi s ním o tom?
Když jim to poprvé.
Já s ním budu mluvit v pátek,
pravděpodobně tak.
Info to tak je.
OK dobře.
Dobře.
OK co se týče efektivity skladování, tak.
V hitcích tam to nějakým způsobem
kolísavě se drží kolem 57% plus mínus.
V chránech to teďka poslední týdny klesá.
Přisuzuju to tomu výprodej.
Toho XPO protože ty lokace se
vyprazdňujou a nedoplňujou.
Co se týče.
Přímo,
na když se člověk jako podívá na detaily
na x pé ó, tak na XP očku,
jako je to kolem 45 nebo něco takového,
takže to XPO dolu.
Co se týče potom 4 řádku,
to jsou nějaké ty skladové distribuce,
tak tady prostě to jsou nějaké crcky.
Jenom asi nás to nemusí trápit.
2 2 za den vychází za ten minulý.
Já jenom prosím tě skladovou distribuci,
skladovou distribuci na explozi a můžeme
z chrášťan být jako normálně spustit
vlastně ve chvíli, kdy.
To úplně přesuneme, je to tak?
Tak jako dalo by se to tak říct
teoreticky nebude jako co ale jo.
Jo.
Jo a teďka je to nějak omezený z tohohle
důvodu?
Ano ano.
Den.
Co se potom týče?
Co se týče potom provozu LCU tak.
Ty expediční joby už se přehouply přes
90% ve prospěch LCU.
Z pohledu zásoby už jsme na 95 procentech
skoro.
A distribuci z příjmu bych nechtěl
přeskakovat. Já já vím, vidím to číslo,
ale já si myslím, že se k tomu dostaneme,
až budem procházet review projektu, tak.
Úterka něco bude mít.
OK co se týká toho přesunu, tak je vidět,
že už to teda začalo jako extrémně
zpomalovat.
Já už jsem to vyprodával pomalu,
že už tam jako z bejvaj furt debilte.
Skákalo jako po 6 3 4 3 procentech teďka
už to zpomalilo jako na úroveň 1 2%.
To jsme na nějakých sedmiset CCA.
Kubíka teďka krášťanek.
Dobře pik tý distribuci z příjmu se
dostanete teda.
V rámci.
Jdeme dál. Díky.
Ano.
Jo.
Prej tak.
Zbytek tady není.
Fajn.
Asi depo tohle asi nic nemá,
smysl to podat.
Já tam jenom řeknu,
že jsem přidal tam vítkovi 2 metriky.
Počet počet systémově roztříděnej job
line na depu a počet systémově vloženej
joblan na depu, protože jsme zjistili,
že tam je jako velký problém s tím,
že sice máme spuštěný jako pod systém pod
pod systémem, ale.
Reálně podíl systémového roztřídění
dumbanek jako na půlce.
Byl z toho důvodu jsem tam přidal tyhlety
matriky, jak to je bohužel sledovat,
jak se to zlepšuje, jak se to zlepšuje,
to je jako novinka.
Systém je spuštěnejch 1. To je jasného.
Vlastně teď by měly bejt 2 snad.
Plzeň se nepletu.
Klesá,
ale tam jsou vlastně ty 2 nejdůležitější,
které souvisej s tím s tím tříděním.
Potom se zapíná dneska v noci jenom.
Jo.
Systémovo jo tak proto tam je 1.
Bílácké Francie takže tam.
Ta expedice je neba.
Souvisí s tím 3 děje.
Jo jinak domluvili jsme se,
že další depo podsystém z toho,
že nebudeme,
dokud to nebude vyřešený na osobně kromě
Plzně a.
Plzni jsou návštěvy, takže bohužel jak to.
Dobře.
OK tak jo.
Pernic.
Na vyšší kapaci příjmů, tak.
Ještě se zeptám,
Martin nevíš jak jak měříte kvalitu
třídění na webu Plzeň řádek 21.
Když tam není spuštěný spuštěný systémově.
To netuším,
ale jakoby tam se systémově nedá ještě
měřit. To se měřit.
Dneska v noci jdeme poprvé pustit tých 7
tras, takže podle mě tohle jsou čísla,
které hlas já dopravy.
Lomítko.
Tak jo.
A dál Teplice zatím nic r máčky a nic tak.
Kapacitu přímo výtek.
Ale tedy vede.
Mě zvyšuje,
ale je to jenom jako operativa.
To je extrémně sklesle produktivita na
potvrzování tohoto stylu.
Davide nevíš proč takhle brutálně klesá
produktivita na potvrzování na příjmu
rostoru?
Myslíš že je to dneska?
Poslední 2 týdny.
Je to jako 15 až 20% níž,
než to bylo 3 týdny zpátky.
Minulej tejden to dokonce bylo jako o 30
procentní.
Tak to se na to podívám. Mně to přijde,
že to šlape normálně.
Jo tady.
Standard je nějakej pěkně nebo kolo 5.
A 70.
2 týdny zpátky 62. Minulý týden 55.
Tys říkal,
že minulý týden jste tam jste tam měli
400 něco doháněli, tak?
Je otázka.
Čím to je způsobený?
Každopádně tady tady z toho vychází,
že ta ten.
Hele ale zase jako na druhej na jo ale
zase jako potvrzovali jsme dost,
tak je to jako divot.
Hele kouknu se na to.
Tak jo zabij pojedeme dál.
Lukáši prosím tě.
Nebo Filip petr dopravníková síť tady.
Trošku.
Pokud řešíme jenom čtečky na dopravníkové
síti,
tak ty se stále nějakým způsobem řeší.
Máme vytipované nějaké množství čteček,
které bude potřeba pravděpodobně vyměnit
nebo nějak upravovat sro na,
což ještě teda jsme našli kapacity.
Zajímavé to probliklo,
každopádně to postupné intenzivní ladění
to pomalu stahuje dolů. A co se týká?
Zásadně to je dobrej,
to je dobrej skok tady.
Jo jo jo.
Ale jako na rovinu, kus toho tam je tím,
že jsme identifikovali nějaké davidové
vylepšováky z kartony a podobné podobné
věci,
ale je tam i spoustu ladění vyloženě těch
čteček.
Jo jo super super dík.
A co se týká TC,
tak asi jak všichni víme 0 velká změna na
OK.
Tohle.
TC nenastala jakože ne,
postavili jsme další,
takže číslo plus mínus oscilují. Jediné,
co tam teďka je vliv je,
že poslední 2 dny máme odpojené jižní
transfery, protože.
Ten dopravník mezi jižními transfersemi a
jižním sortrem je v uvozovkách
rekonstrukci,
protože tam napojujem ten jižní odtah.
Takže to pokleslo spíš v rámci dnů než
jako ten poměr, že by byl ovlivněný.
Dále se vypínali nějaké trasy předpiku,
kvůli tomu teda.
Žiju v tom ano.
Ano ano ano my jsme tam my jsme ten
detail úplně jako neznám,
ale řešili jsme s Michalem saženem kvůli
tomu odpojení,
aby se přenastavil před pik a trasy kvůli
tomu,
že jižní té c nebude vlastně jako funkční
a nepřetekli jsme na severu,
takže odhadl bych, že ano,
ale prefetně to nevím.
Jo.
Martin.
Vim.
Je na 2. Vládne okomentovat robot prosím.
Jo jo jo jo jo tady asi čeho bych se
primárně dotkl počet picků rosteme.
Myslím si,
že tady je docela skvělá práce jak od
provozu,
tak od procesu v rámci obsluhování toho
roapicu, kdy je to ten oto,
najíždíme čím dál tím víc,
takže tady bych se odpíchl od toho,
že takže ten počet picků se nám navyšuje.
Podotýkám,
že ještě stále nejedeme ve třísměnným
provozu stále toto obsluhujeme jenom přes
den.
Takže řekněme, že ten jako celkový cíl.
Je vlastně jako potenciálně teďka jakoby
nižší. Je to z toho důvodu,
že ještě bych tam viděl to,
že provoz se trošku ještě nějakým jako
způsobem ladí a školí rám se roma picků,
ale spíš je teďka primárně.
Máme zaznamenané ještě nějaké bugy nebo
nedostatky,
které jsme navnímali u toho roopiku jako
takovýho máme od toho ten sedač ti
support jak remote,
tak máme stále ještě tenhle týden
poslední tejden supportu člověka od
sedaktu na místě, kde to řešíme.
AS Martinem kišem jsme se bavili,
že ještě řekněme nedoporučujeme.
Přecházet na tu odpolední noční směnu IZ
toho důvodu, že kdyby se něco podělalo,
tak ať ten support přes den jako stále
máme od všech jako odděleních dostupný.
Kvalita robo piku nebo to doopikováno
zásahem člověka nebo kvalita?
Tam se stále pohybujeme na těch nízkých
na těch nižších číslech tady vlastně 0
zásadní změna asi do té doby,
než implementujeme ten nebo než uvidíme.
Výsledky dekantačního procesu si myslím,
že jako nebudou, podotkl bych. Jenom,
že pokud se podíváme na ty čísla.
Podle typu chyb,
který který předpokládáme,
že jsou jako z důvodu dekantace,
nebo víme teďka,
že jsou z důvodu dekantace.
Tak tam se dostáváme na nějakých těch 93
94%,
ale ještě nám do toho stále zasahuje
nějaké to ladění toho sereaktu,
kde se stále ještě pracuje na nějakých
menších věcech,
aby si dotáhli ty poslední procenta.
Takže to bych řekl k tomu tady s tím v
zásadě jakoby spojená. Tady si myslím,
že ty důdky jsou vlastně jako téměř
identický a roboticky pikovatelný.
Scoučka zatím na tady tom nemakáme,
je pro nás primární.
Úkol teďka úloha, je to stabilizovat.
Očekáváme,
že to bude na takový ještě měsíc 2,
než se dostaneme do stabilní formy.
A budeme mít dost odvahy na to
zaimplementovávat další další kusy tady k
tomuto ohledu už Martin bych řekl,
že připravil a teď už se jenom updatuje,
nebo aktualizuje nějaká nová robot aplika
pro procesáky? To má teďka přidaný,
hlavně kuba láznička,
kde mi vlastně vyhodnocujeme analyticky
na základě dat z konzole?
Ty robotické piky a koukáme podle SKUI
podle kategorií.
Kde se nám objevujou ty největší
chybovosti a bude to pro nás řekněme ten
hlavní tahoun.
Kde uvidíme, který produkty fungují,
nefungují a budeme se moct podle toho
rozhodovat, co tam budeme chtít přidávat,
ale opět opakuji. Myslím si,
že tady tu práci začneme reálně dělat
třeba tak až za měsíc,
až se jako opravdu stabilizujeme.
Jo jediný,
co co mě tady vy minulý týden ten robot x
pouštěli postupně do toho plného provozu.
Já bych čekal, že tam bude těch picků víc.
Teďka to jede zhruba teda na 25% 22% času,
to jede 20, 75% času to stojí.
Řádově.
Že tam jelo 6007 spinků,
což je řádově jako 35 hodin při těch 195
za hodinu,
což je 35 hodin čistýho času pickování.
Ano, ale jedeme jenom na jedný směně.
Cože?
Jedeme těch 8 hodin denně.
OK jede se to jenom 8 hodin nechápu.
To bude 1 z příčin.
A 1 ten na vobou ramenách.
Ano od minulého týdne už na obou.
Ten sociální.
Key no tak stejně si myslím,
že tam ještě jako prostor no.
Určitě určitě,
jako to to to ladění nám taky ještě
zabere.
Čas jo ale jenom ať ať víš ty lukózy.
Kdy se teda dostaneme,
kde jsem dostaneme na nějakej ten?
5 dní, 8 hodin ve stanici 5.
60% v rámci využitelnost ten 60.
My se dostaneme na.
Těch.
Kam výš než 11000.
Tu očekávám,
že bysme se tam mohli dostat tak za měsíc
na konci června až uvidíme ty zásadní
jako výsledky tý dekantace a seda k nám
dodá ještě ty fixy,
na který teďka pracujou na jejich straně.
K.
Jo.
Prvo by to asi vše.
Fakt.
OK.
Ttlak perve mějte diskrunce.
Vše je teď dobro.
Dobrý.
Tak kolik teda k prodejim KPI přejdeme
teda na projekty?
Tak já teda z 1 toma tome prosím tě.
1 téma RA.
Jasný jasný.
Promítáme.
Ale v rámci jasně jasně,
ale v rámci toho hlavní věc současnosti
je řešení tý infrastruktury,
kde vlastně máme nějakou 1 nabídku od
maricomu. Čeká se tam ještě na 2.
Od tý cepeny pro pro vyhodnocení.
Tam je něco,
co vám představuje nějaký riziko riziko v
rámci toho dokončení?
Další bod v rámci toho, co se tam řeší,
jsou dopravy,
kdy tam máme dokončení nastavení zpětných
adres a provozních parametrů.
Probíhá tam nějaká finalizace řešení DPD
svozu z cz k.
A když se tam uzavření finální podoby
dopravních procesů před golive zároveň
další bod tam máme.
Řešení belle ZTA prostor,
kdy v rámci rmačka tam sledujeme nějaký
na denní bázi týto palet toho,
abychom tam měli nějak nějakej prostor
během tý realizace infrastruktury,
mohli jsme tam uvolnit ty stávající místa,
kde jsou současný pracoviště.
Mohli se tam.
Jak během toho během toho hejba,
to jsme tam měli prostor prostě pro obě
tyhlety, tyhlety části.
Zároveň něco,
co jsme vlastně minulej tejden vykopli,
tak už řešení řešení nějakýho
harmonogramu toho přesunu. Kde vlastně?
Si chceme říct to,
jak budeme vlastně provozně opouštět
vopouštět chrášťany,
abychom se tam vyspecifikovali nějaký
nějakej datum toho,
nebo jakej má bejt rozestup mezi
ukončením různejch přepnutí doprav na cz
abychom?
Si pak nějaký zboží nemuseli zase.
Mezitím převážet zase je to spojené s
nějakou?
Denní denním reportem toho,
v jakém stavu jsme a za včas zavčas
tohlecto vypnout,
případně nějaká další specifikace,
nějaký další specifikace v rámci toho
dalších změn nastavení na bázi nějakej,
nebo se na bázi emsad,
který řešíme na reklamacích?
A tak podobně.
Toť toť asi v rámci těch reklamací.
Tak co vás čeká teda v tom týdnu do
příštího státu?
Co vás čeká tedy tohle jeho?
Hele, když to jako takhle, když to vezmu,
asi nedokážu říct komplexně v rámci
Michaela,
když to vezmu jako čistě ze svýho pohledu,
tak to, co řešíme, tak je zase příprava.
1 věc je příprava toho harmonogramu,
kde se potřebujeme domluvit domluvit.
Na těch datumech nebo na nějakou tu
posloupnost toho,
co budeme kde vypínat a přepínat?
To je 1.
Část pak když to vezmu IZ pohledu co tam
co tam řešíme načíst na naší části,
tak je příprava změn v rámci v rámci
reportingu sledování různých hodnot v
rámci gadgetu, který který,
který sledujeme, to je něco, co beru,
co se bude dít spíš v příštích 14 dnech
nám přijde teda dovolenou,
ale budu nějakou tuhlectu.
Práci, práci ještě předávat.
Ale pak samozřejmě je to to zmiňovaný
jako myslím,
že jestli jsem tam četl dobře,
včera měla už přijít na výrobu jako petr
to nejhlavnější,
tak to je v rámci tý infrastruktury,
kde vlastně už včera měla přijít ta 2
nabídka. A to je něco,
co případně se bude muset pourgovat,
abychom, abychom měli nějaký datum, datum,
tý realizace. Jako vím,
že tam je zmíněný to,
že ty firmy byly oslovený s tím, že.
Ta nabídka podmiňuje to,
že musí bejt do 1 7 hotovo.
Ale samozřejmě určitě pro nějakou
plynulost by se nám tam hodilo,
kde by to bylo i případně dřív zase,
ať ať tam nemusíme na konci toho měsíce
hnát a případně se tam IV rámci toho
harmonogramu si chceme případně rozložit
tam, kde máme prostor práce.
Zase máme nějaký ne poměr těch
zaměstnanců na HPTA.
A agenturních nebo dodávky služeb.
Tak,
případně ty dodávky bychom mohli
přesunout přesunout dříve,
ale v souvislosti s těmi HPP,
který to mají podepsaný,
tu změnu změnu pracoviště 1 7 tak musíme
i nějak s tímhlectím kalkulovat.
Takhle 1 už to je pryč zkráš to tam
příjemnej.
Petr.
Jasně, jasně, jasně.
To je prostě jako damablův meč.
Hele a prosím tě,
ty dodavatele vám s tím cokoliv chápeš do
nabídky slíbil cokoliv a pak řeknou tu
pravdu jako jo.
Takže.
No jasně, no jasně.
Tady potom teda.
Tohle tohle tohle je teda nějaká hrozba,
nějaké riziko.
Na tuhle se zkuste naměřit prostě jo,
to znamená nějaký pokopák, nebo nevím,
že prostě pravděpodobně asi oni pošlou
nějakou nabídku a jak to bejvá nebere 1
nabídku,
takže bude ještě nějaký vyjednávání,
že jo o tý ceně?
Jasně, jasně jo, hele, já vím,
že dneska to tam akorát Michal urkoval,
jestli jestli už to máme,
abychom z toho stačili všechno schválit
No.
ATD.
Co co tam pak bude následovat jasně jasně.
Ano ano ano ano.
Tohle je společný téma, prosím tě,
izraelskou dole.
Je to společný téma i sro jo. Já vím,
že v tý 1 nabídce bylo něco nějaká
nabídka asi na 2 miliony,
kde bylo právěž zahrnuto zahrnuto anebo v
rámci to bylo přímo v rámci tý sítě,
protože ještě.
Tam na něco čekám a teďka si neuvědomujem,
co to tam Michal zmiňoval,
ale bylo to dohromady s rewes kerem a.
Jo co jo jenom bacha cepenu.
CPR máme IV pražčanech ne úplně ve
stejnej termín je potřebujem,
protože tam máme stejnej deadline.
Je to fakt?
Musíme myslet jako jiné intohocity.
Jo.
A kolik ze zdrojů, případně?
Jo jo.
Hale tady ten detail hlásí přímo nedokážu
říct tady tady vic Michal.
OK, pojďme.
Na reverzní logistiku.
Tady.
Tak tady.
Tady jsem byl taky pořádán Michalem,
tak pokusím se přetlumočit jeho dlouhý
zápis. Co se týče doprav,
tak tam jsme dostali potvrzeno od
balíkářů, že?
Je za je za ně v pohodě.
Ta zpětná adresa směřovat na na třídírnu,
takže to máme potvrzeno.
Aktuálně potřebujeme akorát jako
definovat nějaké poslední detaily jako
třeba gate provozní,
nějaké záležitosti ATD.
Co se týče infrastruktury,
tak tady je to teda viz, to říkal tom.
Tak tady v tomhle případě máme jako
cenovku od mirycomu ale ještě nemáme od
té cepeny, takže tam se ještě čeká.
Respektive bylo to urgováno přes Pavlu
kudymelovou.
Co se týče kamer,
tak tam máme rozmístění kamer ze strany
bug potvrzeno a teď si ještě teď probíhá
zjišťování teda.
Dostupnosti těch kamer.
Potom co se týče it tak jak tady Michal
píše,
tak jsme se sešli s Miroslavem koňou a
Hynkem chrastinou a potvrdili jsme si.
Prošli jsme si nějaké ty požadavky na it
na začátku projektu v teď a.
Víceméně tam snad už by mělo zbývat jenom
potenciálně k nějaké úpravě tiskové
sestavy.
Která který ten štítek je vlastně výstup
z rma,
takže je to takové jako reverzní
logistika slash rma.
No a zároveň teda už nějakým způsobem se
začíná řešit i.
Nějaký harmonogram,
nějaký plán té fyzické relokace s
provozem?
Nějaké teda.
Next teps tak co se týče těch doprav to
jsem zmiňoval tam teďka se finší jenom
nějaké detaily ohledně těch zpětných
adres a podobně.
Na za tu infrastrukturu,
tam je teda taky ta cepena.
Kamery jsem říkal.
Harmonogram jsem taky říkal.
Jo ty rizika je to podobné s tím rma je
tam primárně ten ta cepena.
A tak.
Kolik bych asi?
Za mě.
Máte?
Kamery nám zapojovalo vítěz ten druh na
data.
Všude.
Ještě 1 prosím tě.
Ty kamery zapojoval kdo mi nebo ten vítěz
ten na data?
Učíte.
Nemám tušení, já infrastrukturu.
To je trošku o mě.
Dobře.
Ne.
Tak asi takhle máčku reverzní logistika
téma.
Ale děkujeme, děkujeme oboum.
Pojďme teda.
No povídej.
Nahlásit.
Za vás,
když to teďka pozorujete k 1 7 bude
rmačko v přesunuta nebo tam indikujete
nějaký jako zpoždění?
Je tam nějaký riziko,
nebo nějaká hrozba toho,
že by se to mohlo posunout?
Tak já si myslím jako,
že jak bylo zmíněna ta infrastruktura,
ale říkám já infrastrukturu,
jak jsme se domlouvali,
to jde trošku mimo mě,
takže to nedokážu jako vyhodnotit z
hlediska termínu,
ale to cítím jako asi 1 z 1 z úzkých míst.
Příprava pracovních stanic.
Tome.
O tomhle po barvách.
Chyba.
Teda jako nenapadá mě.
Žádný jako show stoper, který.
By nám mohl bránit v tom.
Jako říkám, co se týče infrastruktury tam.
Neumím odpovědět necítím.
Nebo.
Třeba o infrastrukturu teďka myslím
pracovní stanice stoly,
A co se týče?
prostor na tý na na tý ploše jsou,
takže jako proč se na to ptám,
jsou tady poslední 4 tejdny za 4 týdny.
Máme být přesunutý.
4 týdny uběhnou jako strašně rychle,
tak jestli jestli tam v tuhle chvíli
indikujeme nějaké riziko.
Že by se to nemuselo povést a nebo jestli
nebo je to o tom,
že musíme jenom udělat spolupráci správně,
protože to riziko tam kromě
infrastruktury jako není.
Nedokážu ze sebe říct,
nebo že bych věděl o nějakém problému.
Tohlencto je pravda se Michala Tomáši na.
To už není trvá.
Voda udělal.
Jo.
Docela jo tohle to.
Už jako máme ve finální fázi,
tam bych vám pomalu staví stoly.
Jo.
Vasil má nabraný lidi tak myslím.
OK tam mám napsáno vzkaz Michal.
Terka, prosím tě, provoz toho CU 24.
Lomeno 7.
Ahoj.
Takže aktuálně by jsme tam vlastně řešili
2 témata 1 je gem,
kdy máme teď nějaké prostory v brně?
Bohužel tam vysoká cenovka a 1 věc je
hledáme dál,
nebo respektive dopravy hledají dál a
probíhá tam nějaký vyjednávání o ceně.
Tak to je jako 1 1 z bodů,
který se událo od poslední schůzky a 2.
Vlastně co tady už zmínil tom ta
distribuce z příjmu z chrášťan do LCU.
Vlastně tam došlo k nějaké diskuzi SSPDS
tím, že k 18 5.
Údajně vyčistil objednávky experio czech,
který stále směřovali na chrášťany.
S tím,
že tam ten seznam zůstal ještě relativně
dlouhej s tím, že SPD se hájí tím,
že tam jsou nějaký prostě výjimky.
Dodavatel nejsou schopni předložit ten
seznam a víceméně mě poslali jakoby do
háje,
že že prostě seznam není nebude ani dělat.
Pro to nebudou dál,
takže jsem dneska požádala o support
Ondru.
Zatím zpětnou vazbu nemám. Vím,
že s nima měl od od jedný schůzku.
Můžu si s ním zkusit zavolat odpoledne?
Ale prostě.
Tip.
SPD sahají,
že tam jsou nějaký prostě výjimky,
který má před schválené zase s bílou
kevarem. Věřím tomu,
že to je IO té komunikaci,
jak se to s mírou prostě prodiskutuje dál
nějakej další postup,
ale za mě prostě dokud tam je nějakej
seznam výjimek,
kterej není jasně definovanej, tak tak.
To je prostě nekonečný téma.
Ty objednávky tam budou směřovat pořád,
bude to narůstat a dokud to nebude někdo
hlídat, tak jako to je nekonečný.
Podle mě podle mě.
Podle mě tomu jenom musíme rozumět.
Jako já jsem to říkal Tomášovi mě tady
jako nedrásá 200 převezenejch balíků
denně nedrásá to, že nevíme,
kolik těch 200 převezených balíků denně
jako schválen nebo co jsou,
co jsou výjimky a co je jako lajdáctví.
SPD, že to nerozdělujou?
To je to co mi.
Vadí.
Tak.
To potřebujeme jenom jako mít jasně
viditelně jako rozeznatelný,
ať tomu rozumíme a máme.
Něco v ruce s tím jako můžeme pracovat
jinak přesně jak říkáš, to poroste a.
To je nám tady bude formávat.
Před nosem papírem,
na kterém je dvora s erou.
No on teda asi žádnej papír právě
neexistuje.
Jo oni oni sami nevědí vlastně,
který všichni ty dodavatele jakoby tu
jímku mají.
Jo 13% jako OK jako.
Máme napsáno otočníky.
Tak.
Tak děkujeme.
K tomuhle všechno.
Termína platerní album mi přijde,
co by bral?
Bajku, destrukce ve filologii a materiálu.
Ano tak smlouvu se suplexem máme z jejich
strany podepsanou teďka čekáme na podpis
signy od míry. Mělo by to snad proběhnout.
Dneska žádám o to TN,
aby mi s tím pomohla smlouvu jinak
připomínám, máme koncipovanou tak,
že kdykoliv může vyvolat nějakou novou
aukci.
Nemusíme ke smlouvě přikládat nějaký
seznam těch předmětů do aukce.
Hm.
Smlouva bude pro napsaná na 1 rok a
jakmile bude teda po podpisu,
tak jenom zase.
Připomínám odsurplexu dostaneme nějakého
jejich projektového manažera,
který přijede k nám do skladu nafotí
všechny ty položky, které chceme prodávat,
popíšeme je,
dáme je do jejich systému a zároveň do
toho přidáme naši minimální požadovanou
částku, kterou chceme, za kterou chceme,
aby se to prodalo.
Pojedeme nejspíš 2 kola každý kolo tý
aukce má trvat 3 až 4 týdny a to je v
podstatě asi všechno,
co teď dokážeme říct.
Zkusíme prodat co nejvíc,
co neprodáme tak, jak jsme si říkali.
Nejspíš potom budeme muset vyhodit,
protože už nás bude tlačit čas a prostor
začne.
Ta příjmová sezóna bude potřeba sklady
vyčistit.
Jak teda stroje malovka jo,
díly se tam musel připravený,
to připravili teda.
Všechno stroje,
obalovka i ty díly i notechu,
tak jak jsem říkal nafotíme.
A co ten projekťák jej bude potřebovat,
aby se z naší strany připravil?
Tak to budem připravovat.
To je super,
že já to prostě připravovaný super.
Pořád jsem patří.
Jo plus tam jsou teda ještě otázky. Ano,
jenko.
Podívej.
Je to tam teda kdy to tam teda kdy to tam
teda na nasypeme?
Hele jak jsem říkal dneska nejspíš
dopodpíšem smlouvu,
pak hnedka můžu volat panu vozárovi ze
superxu,
který nám přidělí toho projekťáka.
Ujišťuje mě o tom,
že toho projekťáka má připravenýho,
takže do nějakých jednotek dnů se
domluvíme na návštěvě skladu.
Začnem to nafocovat,
začnem to házet do té aukce.
Za mě by se mělo vyvolat asi víc aukcí,
abychom to úplně nezdržovali.
Pokud týden 14 dní budeme všechno
nafocovat,
tak bych byl pro abychom po 1 týdnu
nafocování uzavřeli jakoby tu 1.
Vyvolali a už tam můžou chodit nějaké
nabídky cenové a potom třeba další další
aukce za další týden.
Takže takhle bych to chtěl co nejvíc
zkrátit, ale počítám,
že tak třeba do té do týdne 14 dnů bychom
mohli 1 aukci spustit.
A co bude 1 stroj sro?
Nebo je nějaká skupina jako věcí,
co tam pošleme?
Určitě tam chci naházet všechny ty stroje,
protože ty máme jako nejvíc mapované.
Najednou.
Máme je nafocené, dal bych tam k tomu,
přidal k té 1 aukci ještě obalový
materiál a jako 2.
Záležitost bych asi řešil té netržší
materiály,
protože to je taková jako obsáhlejší
větší kapitola.
Je tam hodně těch položek jsou různorodé
a nevím,
jak moc budeme schopný fotit jednotlivé
šroubky, které tam mají třeba k vyhození.
Jo původně jsme chtěli něco vyhodit,
ale říkáme,
pojďme to dát taky do té aukce.
Asi jo.
Jo, takže tohle nějak plynule?
Prostě podle toho,
jak to bude pro nás nejvýhodnější,
tak to budem zkoušet nastavit.
Jo plus tam teda je ještě otázka,
vo kterejch jsme se bavili a asi i naživo
s některýma lidma jsou to ty regály,
jsou to ty spádový regály.
Zde je budeme používat ještě někdy v
budoucnu,
nebo dávaj smysl to taky vyhodit,
protože ty zabíraj relativně dost místa a
nejsem si jistý,
jestli všechno v budoucnu použijem
minimálně ty spáďáky linku,
díky tam padlo něco jako to ISS,
kvůli kterýmu sme to v minulosti.
Pozastavili to vyhazování,
ale já nevím v tuhle chvíli.
Jestli nějak pokračuje víc než v tom,
že jsme si ho někde jako nahoru postavili
Tak já.
a testovali jsme?
Já taky ne, ale to by měl vědět Honza.
Jo s Honzou, když jsem se bavil,
ještě než ty,
jsi na to napsal to ISSO tom,
jestli jestli ty regály,
někdy bude potřeba, tak on říká,
že s nimi někdy nepočítá.
Takže asi tak dobrý rozjedu,
znova kolečko na to ISS chápu a uvidíme.
A jako minulej rok.
Jo,
minulej rok jsme to zastavili kvůli tomu
ISS.
Teď by k tomu umožnili bejt snad nějaký
jako výstupy,
protože to tady kluci ve sklepě jako
testovali poslední 3 měsíce. Tak nevím,
jestli se řeklo,
že do toho jdeme nebo nejdeme si myslím,
že ne.
Enhnm.
Že si jako dělal ten to to r míčko a
ukázalo se, že to nemá ty výtvory,
který to vít mělo. Tak si myslím, že.
To bude o tom rozmluvit,
to budu prodat já nevím jestli to tak je
Vyhodit.
Jasný.
prodat ty tyhle ty páťáky těch.
Ty jo prodejny no nevím jak moc to bude
prodejné.
Můžeme se zase poradit s tím superxem?
Uvidíme.
Jo.
Dobře.
Tak jo díky.
Rád píšu, poznám tu s firewarem hr.
Tak děkujeme tak Martin, prosím tě.
2 témata jde.
O Plzeň 1.
Testovací provoz dneska v noci se spustí
7 tras na systémová.
Následně z 1 na 2 se spustí z višných 15
tras. Tady se navýšil počet tras,
protože došlo o vlastně prepočítaní a
preplánování tras na základě objemu aut
včetně nějakého započítaní,
aby PO expe o produktu a tady ten roll
vlastně jde skrz.
Všechny depa proto nám vzniknou nové
trasy.
A 8 6 je poslední krok vlastně na Plzni a
to je presun XL depa.
Za starého depa na nové s tím,
že dneska jsme byli vlastně na nějakém
školení a tam bude ještě potřeba,
aby tam víte, kdo toho šlápnul.
Co se týká nějakých systémových vylepšení,
protože to je taky jako trošku krkolomná
situace.
Jinak wifi máme připojenou jedinou věc,
kterou s it infra řešíme,
je kamerový systém.
V tyto chvíli máme nainstalováno 6 kamers
věštne kamery nejsou,
potřebujeme je dokoupit.
Já jsem to konzultovala s ondrom,
ten to trošku jako rozporuje,
takže až se dneska vrátí z holt,
asi se potkáme v Plzni, tak to dořešíme.
Co se týká nějaké odpočinkové místnosti,
kterou my jsme tam plánovali,
tak tam byla na auditě Veronika wigris a
potřebujeme pevné zázemí,
takže to taky řešíme s Ondrou.
Buďme tam muset doplnit konťák nějakej,
aby tam byla kuchyňka a šatny jako
stavebně oddělení.
Nemůžeme to mít takhle jako jenom
provizorně udělané,
i když tam máme 4 lidi jenom.
Co se týká organizační struktury,
tak nás top nových zaměstnanců od 20.
Platin nastoupilo 50% či že 2 AS vyšli
dorazí.
Reporting.
Včera jsme malý meeting s Tomášem
vandasem.
David blahovic taky něco spustil přes
power BI. Zvolala jsem na to meeting,
abysme si řekli,
jakým směrem dál tady v tom pokračovat,
protože něco už máme vyvinuto.
Next jsteps.
Spustěn je systémových abetras obě 2
části pressun XL zpětný tok.
A co potřebujeme, tak jsou tady ty triry,
ktoré už tady meleme 2 měsíce,
že je potřebujeme stejně se nehýbou,
a to je ten důvod,
i co Hynek říkal na začátku ten hosín a
tak dále.
Ty Jerry jsou tam od března.
A nehly se,
takže jako nevím kdy to bude hotový.
Vezmu s Vaškem to bychom museli 2 musím
asi vezmu.
Dobrý, tak budeš,
což je to nějak vykopírovat?
On nemá Hynek je má.
Jo.
No a jsou v tý frontě it gondole
mimochodem.
Ne to tam jako pod nebem no.
Potřebujem zdá hned.
Teď nám zobrazdí i další den.
Pane může být jak?
Co víte tořít?
Dobrý den jinak.
Já myslím, že už tam.
To vezme s Vaškem skřivánkem dobrý.
Čtete.
Ano jo jako.
Já já si myslím že vyšší a moc bude lepší
a my už jsme zkusili všechno,
co jsme mohli s vítkem.
Chápu chápu.
OKOK, dobrý, dobrý, dobrý.
Systémové třídy.
OK tak jak zmiňoval Hynek hosín,
je to systémové trasy jsou spuštěné,
Pis.
máme tam stále problémy,
některé se týkají it věcí a další se
týkají nějakých naší nedodržování postupů.
Nový bejžou tam máme nabídku od miricomu,
kterou na míra neschválil.
Bylo nám doporučené,
teda bylo mi doporučené ji obrátit se na
cepenu, takže čekám na nabídku od cepeny.
Golive určitě musíme rozdělit na 2.
Skupiny. Pak následně,
protože 25 ras a 25 řidičů,
ktorý jsou trošku na tom jako hůř než v
hosíně, tak to bude masakr už už tak a.
A už víte, jak rozdělíte,
jak a kdy to rozdělíte?
Až bude doinstalováno váš to,
co má být doinstalováno,
tak až pak se rozhodně ne kde bude golife
bez toho to nepustíme dál.
Já to teď teď nevím.
Jo takže takže 1 z milníků černou bude
něco takovýho podobnýho?
Asi.
Ne.
Pestrou přípravný.
V případě v červnu uvidíme milníky,
jak jste to rozdělili a kdy spouštíte ran?
No tak jako hele už jsme to neplánovali
1000500 krát jestli it nedoinstaluje ty 2
giry minimálně,
tak prostě to bude v červenci nebo v
srpnu. Já to nevím.
Ne v pohodě,
ale když se nám to objeví v nějakých
millících.
No objeví,
no ale já to nechám takhle do tý doby,
než budeme vědět něco víc. No.
Jasný jasný tak vratimula k Příbrami.
Vratimov bude až.
Vlastně pobočka se připravuje,
až bude systémovo vyvinutá pobočka.
Můžeme vybrat trasy a pripravit si
plánovaně trasná na test systému.
Jestli to tam budeme,
to muset jít ze školy, ty lidi a gem.
Tam se čeká na nové depo.
Dneska tam byl piter čechák. Nevím,
terka možná ví něco víc,
ale já jsem s Petrem ráno mluvila a
uvidíme, jak dopadne ta hala ten výběr.
Takže já nevím, jestli to zamítli,
nebo nezamítli to nevím ještě.
Co se týká tady toho projektu,
tak celé se nám to goly hlavně gemu bude
šupat v čase určitě nebude to koně černá,
to tak je na minimálně koně.
Září kvůli tady tomu.
To už nám konsoliduje vlastně s tou
stanovenou strategií OSKD tam se všechny
depa v podstatě zastavili a jediné depo
ktoré se bude.
Provozovat na systému web,
tak je depo mokra.
Dokonce května maj padnuť výběr tady těch
trochu variant,
které jsem tam dala a následně by se
vlastně nezačal tendr na dopravce,
ktorý beatam provozoval,
takže tohle taky jako není úplně ještě
jako jisté, že to dopadne.
Teď to mají dopravy vlastně v rukách AZ
wishok.
Jasný.
Trass se vlastně preklápají nějaké nějaké
věcizoraného Slovenska,
se preklapajů na directi priamoze s kl c
trik AZ wish of tras prostě z wishec dep,
které jsou v katastrofalům staveb,
se musí udělat strategie za mě 20. 27.
Bolest ano.
A tady jsem jenom hodila ty 2 2 reporty
jak máme něco už konzoli nainstalované a
něco je tady power BI.
Já jsem to sem dala jenom tak jako pro
info.
Takže za mě nový bij infra dotáhnout
vratimou do systémů nastavit a.
Pracovní.
A pak budeme čekat na it.
Teda na i na vývoj.
Leo wels to je myslím,
že to je čistě jako vývoj. Jo,
já si myslím,
že jako velká část toho problému leží.
Leží v tom,
že se porušuje proces na chrážděnech.
Já jsem si to dneska s Davidem ubrem
vyříkával. Vítek u toho byl taky takže.
Si myslím, že dokonce jsme se domluvili,
že od zejtra bysme tam jako měli vidět
zlepšení snad.
Ten.
Jak.
Takže by se to jako se mělo zlepšit?
Samozřejmě to jako nevyřeší 100%,
ale jestli se jako z 50% dostaneme na 50
na na 95, tak si myslím,
že jako nic nebrání tomu,
abychom pokračovali.
Já si myslím,
že tohle bude hrozně kolísat na základě
toho,
jak budou chrášťany a třídírna stíhat.
Takže čím sk kur zafixujeme, tu tu džíru,
aby tam mohli to manuálem vkládání
vlastně jako pokračovat. V tom,
když jim teče do bot,
Ale jako tam.
tak to prostě naložit.
Nemaj normálně vkládat,
když to tam manuálně vkládaj tak jako
není. Není informace o tom,
který balínky jsme do toho auta naložili
a který jsme tam naložili,
pokud to vkládají všechno přes konzoli,
tak tam vložej prostě 100% řádků,
který tam viděj.
V nějakým stavu a vůbec jako nestří
realitu, kdy se tam musí nakládat to,
co fyzicky dáváme do auta,
to tam pustíme jako vožat ten svozák,
aby ten vosín věděl, co přijel.
To má následně bude síla,
jinak to jako nebude dobře řídit.
Já s tím souhlasím ale.
Ale Vítek se hlásí,
tak ať ať to řekne on jako.
Takový tyup.
Strašně mi, to je jasné. On se říká, že.
Druhej pokus.
Jo už se těší na.
Výborně, chtěl jsem jenom to dodat,
že vlastně jsme to řešili poměrně
drasticky. To znamená,
odebrali jsme na to ruční vkládání práva
lidem, který je nemají mít. Znamená to,
že teďkon tohle to právo už má jenom
admin vedoucí směny,
takže už to tam nebude moc. Řeknu,
kde kdo vkládat ručně,
takže proto očekáváme to to zlepšení,
nebo minimálně ten viditelnej rozdíl.
A že tohle budem dál sledovat do budoucna?
Dávám tohle teda jako.
Musíme od toho provozu vyžadovat, protože.
Samozřejmě jako dopravy tady na nás
nastupujou s tím, že.
Že jako ty na ten svaza vkládáme co
chceme vy, to je pravda.
Potom o nich chceme svalda za něco,
co oni nedostali ani.
Pokud to, pokud to máme, pokud máme jako.
Vyžadovals že doručuje toto jsme dali
taky musíme dávat to,
co jako fyzicky dávali auto,
tak musíme dávat na svobozák.
To fungovalo,
nevím proč já to tam jako vkládám ručně.
Inc.
Teda Martin děkujeme, děkuji, budeme.
Tak.
Další téma,
výtlak 310000 storgepoint z autostore
lucko poprosím tě jenom jo.
15 30 bral.
Targlutsko.
OK tak Martin mi tady dal jenom krátký
update z jeho strany,
když byste si to rozklikli,
tak jsou tam nějaký nějaký dashboardy
nějaký obrázky?
Ale z toho důležitého zprovoznilo se
automatický hlášení přes matea na výpadky
autostoru,
domluvila se zá půjčka binrest krobota z
autostorem a řeší se hardwarový tlačítka
in house.
Programování a budou se testovat v
prašťanech.
Vyhneme se nákupu těch předraženejch
tlačítek.
Co se týče hardwaru,
tak pro tunel bychom většinu hardwaru.
Možná už všechen měli mít k dispozici.
Příští týden začneme postupně
implementovat na porty ve spolupráci s
provozem.
Co se týče stavební přípravy,
tak zítra přijde stabil realizovat
vypouštění a demontáž brnklerů.
EPS by se měla realizovat v příštím týdnu.
Zatím nemáme potvrzený termín.
Roman máme potvrzenej od dvacátýho
druhýho 6 u elektro máme zadání na cepenu,
čekáme na nabídku AU dat,
máme nabídku od miricomu,
dáváme dohromady zadání pro pro další
dodavatele.
Bylo nám doporučena, přepena.
Takže to je tak všechno k tomuhle
projektu?
Vedeni k položte ty sprejklady.
Cože?
Kdo bude vypouštět springlery?
Stabil.
To je blbost, to nemůžu udělat.
To musí udělat správce bodovek sima.
Bacha na to.
Disk.
Je to domluvené, aleš valšek to domlouval.
V koordinaci se simou a se stabilem jsou
domluvený požární hlídky od zítřka od 8
hodin s Davidem.
Ano,
ale hele vždycky to ale dělalo stabil.
Jo to je, to je v pořádku vašku.
My jsme to samé dělali před 2 tejdnama
nebo více,
než jsme dělali ty průchody tou podlahou
proto dopravníkovou síť.
Dobře.
OKA tena ten proman tady teda 26 přijde,
to se teda potvrdilo pa 20.
Ano to máme potvrzený,
že dvacátýho druhýho 6 začnou realizovat.
Super.
Super tak to je dobrý,
to je taková jako pastevní zpráva.
No, pořád je to ještě tak,
že to stihneme selement a domluvený na
Perfektní.
Jo.
půl půlka 3 tejden v červenci,
že by potřebovali v tom tunelu začít.
Takže máme tam docela ještě prostor?
A ještě mi řekni,
projišťuje tu lůžkovku sám tu plošinu sám.
Má ji v nabídce, takže ano.
Nebo.
Jo jo OK.
Paráda ing tady něco k tomuhle.
Pro ty.
Tak para sebe.
Stihne metr 29. 6.
Cena.
Proma nestihneme do dvacátýho devátýho 6
a.
Jak jsem říkala,
prostě máme domluveno s alementem,
že budeme potřebovat v tunelu ty prostupy
dělat do půlky července.
Oni vlastně začínají.
V červenci začínají s přesunem AS
instalací nabíječek a vkládáním robotů a
na porty se přesouvají až v půlce
července ke konci července.
A případně jsou schopný,
nebo nemají problém otočit realizaci,
že by začali na západě a šli do tunelu až
potom.
Takže tohleto máme jako zkoordinovaný?
OK, takže počítáte s.
Počítá to teda s tím, že.
Si to nahradíte?
Správným harmogramem na straně evamentu.
Aby je to nebrzdilo.
Ano.
To ega asi kam uhnout.
To je dobrý.
OK tak jo tady asi děkujeme a 2 téma
navýšení kapacity příjmů.
Příjemný.
No tak tam se nám povedlo bobídkovi se
povedlo dotáhnout layout zdi tím pádem
máme připravený layouty přímo všech LC.
Stejně s layoutem zdi připravil i layout
BPO stanic po přesunu.
Finální počet byl rozhodnutej nebo
odsouhlasenej na 10 stanic,
to znamená k těm 6. Co tam máme,
tak přidáme další 4.
Takže řešíme schválení hardwaru pro 4
nové stanice?
Řešili jsme tam ještě 2.
2 verze layoutu s otočenýma s neotočeným
výtahem,
ale jako interně jsme se shodli jak s
vítkem. Myslím si,
že i on to konzultoval s provozem.
A počítám, že linku IS tebou,
že výtah otáčet nebudeme a necháme tu
variantu bez otočení.
Vycházelo nám to v layoutu,
že tam i tak bude jako víc prostoru než
kdybysme ten výtah otočili.
Super.
Takže máme máme layout těch stanic
vlastně slouží jako podklad pro elektro a
datový sítě.
Co se týče těch další věcí,
tak jsme otestovali na příjmu ten
rescanner víceméně ten ohlas z provozu
nebyl příliš pozitivní.
Z hlediska jako nějakýho zrychlení nebo
pro ně efektivity práce říkali,
že radši sáhnou i po drátový čtečce než
po tomhle tom skeneru.
Takže vlastně pro pro ně je nejlepší ta
bezdrátová,
ale když by se vzal ten žebříček,
tak co jsme od nich zjistili tak na 1.
Místě bezdrátová čtečka na 2 drátová a na
3 až tenhle ten.
Rukavicovej hřbetný scanner.
S Lukášem tam jsou jsme se domluvili,
když už ten skener máme na na zapůjčení,
že ho otestujeme ještě na balení.
Abysme měli když tak i zpětnou vazbu na
na jiném procesu.
Dobrý.
Pro pro ty no cože?
Teď mi začínáš citrovat teďka promiň
promiň teda teďka co se týká toho bb l
prostoru,
tak ten začíná se teďka připravovat. Jo.
Ono tohle je.
Ano.
Podle toho layoutu,
tam tam to všechno koordinujeme s Lukášem.
Vlastně cepena dostala zadání co tam,
kam přesně má přivést elektru.
Podle toho LI.
Pak je tam ještě poslední věc,
a to je schválený schválení layoutu u
toho rozděleného portu.
Byli jsme tam v pátek s Ondrou a svítkem.
A řešili jsme to IZ hlediska jako
ergonomie a toho, jestli potřebujeme,
nebo jestli tam,
bude to pevný pracoviště nebo ten mobilní
stolek, tak víceméně jsme se shodli,
že IZ hlediska jako ergonomie,
tak bysme tam dali tu drátovou čtečku
bysme pevně uchytili,
aby sloužila jako stacionární čtečka.
K tomu bysme dali bezdrátovou čtečku.
Kterou vlastně ti operátoři,
budou mít buď na naskenování palety a
nebo lokace.
A máme domluvily jsme se,
že připravíme jakoby 2 varianty nebo 2
pracoviště 1 bude s mobilním stolkem,
který by byl v prostoru mezi paletou a
tím levým binem nebo tím levým portem.
2 varianta by byla s tím pevným stolem u
zdi vedle portu.
Bavili jsme se o tom IS provozem oni jako
říkali, že by ideálně z toho,
jakoby chtěli vyzkoušet AZ toho bysme pak
měli získat nějakou zpětnou vazbu a bejt
schopný říct,
jak bude vlastně ty porty vypadat.
Takže z toho jako vyplývá, co nás čeká,
čeká nás upřesnit si rozsah toho hardwaru
teďka jako rozjíždím schválení pro ty 4
nové stanice to asi budu řešit dřív,
než si rozhodneme,
jak budou vypadat ty party.
Abysme aspoň tohle měli připravený
zahájit ten přesun do toho stání z podle
toho layoutu a pak jsme se tam bavili o
nějakém procesním testování v průběhu
června, takže na to na to se připravit.
Otázky k tomu.
Proč tam jsou 2 čtečky.
Jednadrátová 1 bezdrátová,
dejte bezdrátová,
taky můžou být nekonstacionárně a jenom,
když jí potřebuji,
tak si ji prostě z toho doku vezmou, ne?
To může,
ale Ondra vlastně tam původně mluvil IO
něčem jako overhecksenru,
aby prostě tam byla 1 1 stacionární a.
A tu bezdrátovou si vezmeš jenom když ji
jako budeš potřebovat.
Tam, kdybych potřeboval.
Ale.
Není to zbytečné,
nemůžeš si vzít tu bezdrátovou,
když ji potřebuješ najednou?
Pojďme se o tom bavit někde bokem, prosím.
Rob.
Dobře.
Ten ohradí.
Asi ta zpráva je přijata přijasnění.
Lucku děkujeme.
Tak filipe, tvůj tvůj kvartes.
Spravné palety 1 je RFID komunikace?
Je tak.
Tak.
Tak tady jsme udělali úspěšný posun,
teda datovýma sítěma, který máme,
řekněme připravený z hardwarového
hlediska, takže brány jsem u objednal.
Už stačily i dorazit mám je teďka na
facilitce,
dostali jsme k tomu nějaké instrukce a
zadání, jakým způsobem se mají montovat.
To jsem teďka s klukama domluvený,
že do konce tohoto týdne je připravit dle
specifikace a rovno je teda propojí v
rámci sítí AV rámci zdroje na elektra,
takže tam jsem s klukama single.
Jakmile tohle proběhne.
Tak jsme v zásadě jako připravený na to
testování,
bude tam ještě jenom 1 vedlejší věc.
A to je to, že ty sítě musíme donastavit,
protože síťaři nám vlastně jako já jsem.
Původně to chtěl udělat obráceně.
To znamená definovat specifikace zařízení
a připravit ty sítě dopředu.
Síťaře mi řekli, že ne,
že se to dělá obráceně,
že nejdřív máme zařízení zapojit a že oni
ho potom dál jako nakonfigurují,
takže tam budeme mít ještě jenom takovou
1 malou extra.
Věc,
ale tam už jsem domluvený i případ s
Lukášem tom jsou na support,
že jakmile dostaneme fajfku od facilitky,
takže během 1 dne jsme to schopný
propojit na konfigurovat a zařídit
rezervaci DDHCP adres. Takže za mě.
Já tam teďka dávám to riziko,
jelikož jsme původně si říkali,
že od června by jsme to spustili a asi
jako všechno teďka nasvědčuje tomu,
že bysme to měli mít připravený.
Jenom je to pro mě takový samozřejmě má
ušima.
A že vlastně jako do konce tejdne,
to všechno dokončíme.
A příští týden jsme ready tak?
Se jako ještě nejsem jistej,
dávám to jako riziko. Myslím si,
že to tam ještě můžeme trošku nabourat na
tý konfiguraci těch antén a jim teď říkáš,
že ty antiry jsou už jako z výroby
přednastavený a jakmile se propojí,
tak jsou ready.
Já jsem u tady těch tasků vždycky takovej
skeptickej mě to historicky nikdy
nefungovalo, takže říkám riziko,
že počítám asi jakoby s tím,
že v pondělí nebo po tý instalaci zjistím,
že tam ještě nějaká dokonfigurace.
Potřeba.
Prosím tě,
Filip naposledy probíhá nějak reklamace
Každopádně.
těch palet, plavbu nebo.
Prosím tě,
ty palety jako obecně plazgu jako tu
reklamaci jsme v uvozovkách uzavřeli s
tím,
že palety jsem předal Davidovi kupcovi.
Oni je využijou,
mají pro ně jako funkčnost,
takže my jsme si je normálně jako
odkoupili a ty plazgerový palety dáváme
provozu a ty 2 palety už aktivně
testujeme 2 týdnem už jsou na ropasu,
ty od toho českého dodavatele tam už
dokonce z toho máme nějaký 1 dobrý v
pozitivní feedbacky.
Jak to ovlivňuje ropaso?
Údržby počet jako chybovosti se nějakým
způsobem snížil.
Já jsem teďka 6 úkoloval kluky pepu
lomeno, Michala sažina,
aby to zkusili projít a trošku jako
propočítat.
Jestli teda efekt je opravdu jenom
pocitovka a nebo jestli tam jako máme
nějaké reálné čísla,
že jsme to zlepšili o 10 20% a tak
podobně.
Ven a proto ta testování zahájení
testování. Máte nějaký firm?
Jo načetnutej?
Co.
Hele řeknu to na rovinu,
že to budeme jako řešit tak trošku jako
ad hoc tím,
že ten timeline se tady jako měnil ze dne
na den a komplikace se objevovaly,
projevovaly a zmizely,
tak půjdeme to prostě řešit,
až ta situace přijde teďka dopředu.
My ten proces jako před domluvenej máme.
Tomáš alze má jako připravenou nějakou
skicu nebo IU toho,
jak monitorovat datově.
Nebo nějakej tool jak datovej monitorovat
ty antény?
S provozem máme předdomluvenej proces pro
nějaký depa?
Chceme ty plalety začít využívat za
nějakých gitech.
Podle toho tam ty refi dan the
instalujeme,
ale nedostal jsem se do tý fáze,
že bych tu suverénně jako zaplánoval s
klukama. Asi už jenom z toho důvodu,
že se to tady milionkrát změnilo a chci
to jako řešit ve chvíli,
kdy to jako bude reálný.
Kontrolu.
To se dá dělat.
Tak jo děkujeme tak dopravníková síť v
krátčanech.
24.
Tak.
Dopravníkovou sítí,
hlavně ta se samozřejmě stavby jiného
sjezdu nám tam všechno bych řekl,
to je docela docela dobře.
Jdeme teda dle plánu.
Aktuálně teda máme postavený dopravník
vlastně ve 3.
Patře máme jižní 100 postavený celý
propojení VPP lupem už je taky hotový,
už máme propojený jižní sjezd IS na SPO
tam nás potom teda ještě čeká otázka.
Zase nějaké malé odstávky,
kdy budeme ten s ploop jako takový
propojovat.
Tam ještě stále čekám na kluky,
jestli neteku na nějakou časovou definici.
Ať to můžu davidům dát vědět,
oni na to čekají,
ať už to máme za sebou a teďka v mezičase.
Tento týden se dle plánu stavěla a
napojovalo jižní sjezd na odtah jižních
transforsel, což i ten důvod,
jak zmiňoval Lukáš krejčí.
Proč ty transformace jsou teda odstavené,
takže tam ta stavba jde si myslím,
že docela dobře dle plánu za těmi podle
in packu v rámci jako programování říkáme,
že do toho června to jako stíháme tak,
jak jsme si to původně plánovali.
Nějaká rizika tam zatím asi jako
drastická.
Drastická nevidíme.
S tím teda spojená věc, kdy Lukáš kječí,
už teda připravil nějaké zadání pro TMS,
aby se zaintegrovali.
Vlastně ta ta mapa toho jižního sjezdu do
TMS. Na to je schůzka zítra,
takže tam se když tak dozvíme nějakej
feedback,
ale po jako ta diskuze ZTMS už jako
nějakou dobu trvá.
Mělo by se s tím počítat, takže doufám,
že to bude pozitivní a.
My tady pak ještě s Lukášem teda řešíme.
Sepadátně ty ostatní otázky těch částí
toho dopravníku a ať už je to řekněme
spíše v rámci jako třídící kapacity.
Tady nám běží nějaký ten side projekt,
který tady máme s Pepou AS Michalem
společně s Lukášem,
kdy řešíme trošku tu utilizaci toho toho
ropase.
Abysme si tam natáhli ten počet trust,
kterej jsme původně očekávali v rámci
nějaký předtuchy toho projektu.
A my s Lukášem ještě do toho řešíme.
Jak bysme dokázali lépe rozplést ty toky
mezi a bez WA jižní sorter tím,
jak nám teďka poteče,
vlastně je kombinovanej tok z jižního
sjezdu a transfersel tady.
Řeknu na rovinu,
že mám trošku jako optimistickou
představu, to jako zkusit do pátka,
rozlousknout tu ideu,
jak to udělat jako máme.
Máme na to teďka připravenej nějakej tul.
Jestli to chceme zkontrolovat,
ale vnímám to jako s nějakým velkým
otazníkem.
Každopádně z nějakýho času časově
harmonogramovýho hlediska.
Když to teďka řeknu trapným způsobem,
nás to úplně netlačí.
Máme ještě s Lukášem,
jako často rozhodnutí někdy do půlky
června udělat,
protože do tý doby i doteď je stejně
vlastně zabitej na dodělání.
Spojky,
ale i tak bych to akorát tadyten tejden
měl buďto jako vyřešený a nebo měl aspoň
jako jasnou představu,
kdy příští tejden to odpověď budeme znát.
Já myslel, že ta vánočka na konci?
Se napojuje na tu ještění spojku.
Ano,
ale my jí teďka máme v uvozovkách
zakonceptovanou.
Ona není jako zaprojektovaná a je to
hlavně z toho důvodu,
že my stále s Lukášem probíráme jako
možnosti a otázky, jestli to chceme,
protože.
Za předpokladu,
že příští rok budeme instalovat
technologií třízení tak všechno,
co teďka vlastně postavíme nad rámec toho
projektu, budem příští rok bourat.
Jo a my se jako chceme vyhnout tomu,
že i kdyby to investici dávalo smysl
propalovat čas na stavbě něčeho, co víme,
že jako za rok zbouráme.
Jo.
Ano.
Co se týče rizik.
Jo.
Ano vašku.
Ten bangladéš tady do.
Jo, co se týče rizik,
tady jsme s dotykem stále na stejné vlně.
Já jsem domluvený s Pavlem vlčákem,
že se nějak tu situaci trošku osvětlím a
příští týden v úterý.
On mi to jako vysvětloval ty kapacitní
důvody, který tam teďka maj.
Asi si to jako probereme.
Rozhodl se na příští úterý,
ať dáme jako finální výsledek,
týká se nás to i obecně toho tématu z
těch čteček,
kde ještě teda doplním vlastně jako
Lukáše s předtím,
kde facilitka udělala poměrně.
Slušnou značnou práci a myslím,
že kdo to patří. Velký díky.
Oni těch čteček,
ale už i tam jsme vlastně nabourali,
že co nám facilitka byla schopná udělat,
udělali a ten zbytek potřebuje vyřešit
přes i notec. Takže tady doufám,
že ty kapacitní topiky si s Pavlem
ročákem nějak rozlouskneme,
teda příští úterý.
Já jsem s ním na to domluvenej,
on si to teďka nějak připravuje. Sepisuje,
aby rovnou dal nějaký finální feedback a
mohli jsme si trošku ukotvit ten skegel.
Tak když se podívám tady sem.
Tady bylo devorance našeho května
potvrdit potřeby v rámci Bangladéše.
Mám tu tady naše proud.
Jo tak asi do tý příští středy,
já to tam byl tu příští středu tady v tom
100 už snad rozkotvím.
Posouvat teda jo.
Děkuji ti.
Tak pojďme dál počívají na zapojení
jižních transferce nebo konviru.
Forhout, jasně.
Hele jo je to stále,
on ho zase dám jenom nějakou krátkou
storku.
My tam máme už vykopnuto stavební
připravenost.
Máme tam z toho už nějakou otázku jenom
ohledně upřesnění elektropřívodu pro
jednotek,
kterou teďka řeším a aleš už by měl
poptávat ty ostatní věci,
viz teda pro tu ten propoj průchod
podlahou s přítahem prázdných KLTA,
potom tam máme.
1 ten kabinetovej elektrickej rozvaděč,
kterej by tam potenciálně překážel.
Respektive on nám pro ten lap nepřekáží,
ale jakmile to zastavíme,
tak se k tomu kabinetu nedostaneme.
Takže tohle tohle běží,
aleš to poptává a tady jako můj cíl zatím
než ten projekt vykopneme,
což by mělo být přelom června. Července,
tak můj cíl je aspoň už to tam všechno
dopředu připravit, ať tady tu věc máme,
řekněme.
Za sebou.
Jo.
Ale časově tady prosím tě, máš nějaký 3.
Teďka ty? Co je příprava hotovo,
nákup materiálu hardware a přes montáž
hardware hotovo.
Do pátku jsou ty 1 2 a to je na
dvanáctýho.
Ale je to reálný vůbec ještě.
Tady se jako přiznám,
že já jsem si to tam jako napsal.
Jo spíš jako pro sebe, jako poznámku.
Abysme jako věděli.
Každopádně jako procurement už vlastně
běží ten ten ten nákup.
Pátek je tam pro mě jenom takovej jako
přátelskej,
připomínač ať to jako checknu sinotekem,
že to je v pohodě.
Stavební příprava reálně je potřeba,
aby byla hotová do konce června.
Já to tam mám jenom pro sebe,
abych to zkusil jako udělat dříve,
Jo.
ale to už vím teďka, že nezvládám.
Já se tě pátek pozvu a napíše mi nějaký
nový termíny.
Dobře.
To budeš člověk víc nebo toto šoupraví,
to je v pohodě,
Než.
jako to není pro nic špatného.
To šoupnem prostě jo.
Dobrá.
OK.
Tak.
Dotaz.
Až se začnou stavět,
nebo až se začne předělávat to vytahování
na jihu musíte omezovat.
Musíme omezovat jižní vytahování na jihu.
Ano určitě omezíme to minimálně v tom
ohledu,
Jednoznačně.
Pak.
že pokud tam zůstane něco funkčního,
tak to bude vlastně jenom ta manuální
stanice.
Ale my potřebujeme i ten aktuální 2 d
vytahovák vlastně přemontovat do toho
finálního layoutu s těmi 3.
Už jenom z toho důvodu,
že nejde jenom o posunutí,
ale jde IO konstrukční změnu.
Navazuji na nějaké ty problémy s tím 2 d,
které jsme měli,
jelikož to byl asi takový ten 1 prototyp,
teď už známe ty.
Teď už máme novej design.
Od Ondry knížka těch 2 dita s nějakýma
změnama na energořetězech a podobných
věcech,
takže tam to 2 d č o to 2 d přijdeme a
budeme mít kapacitu pouze tý jedný
manuální stanice.
To znamená, že to omezíme o půlku.
Těch jiných dá se.
My budeme muset vypnout.
Jinými slovy budeme muset vypnout nějakou
část certifiku, jo.
Asi ano, ale řekl bych,
že menší jo ta manuální stanice.
My jsme vlastně schopný pokrýt celý ty
transfery na severu 2. Můžeme teda říct,
že teoreticky tam jako zvládáme dělat 300,
takže my stále z nějakých jako 70% si
myslím,
že ty transfersny na jihu jako obsloužíme
jenom teda bohužel ručně pouze.
Chápu vím, že.
To je to je jako.
Chce se mi dodat,
že v některých kratších úsecích to bude
muset vypnout kompletně,
protože tam bude i nějaká drobná
přestavba v tom dopravníku.
Určitě bude se připojovat PLCA tak
podobně,
takže nějaký jakoby krátkodobý výpadky
tam definitivně budou jako kompletní.
Chápu, že je to za měsíc a půl.
Jenom tohle bude potřeba velmi důkladně
projít tady s Davidem,
aby na to byli kluci připravený. Jo,
jako změnit ty toky a tak dále.
Jo jo my my s tím počítáme,
je to nějaká lessens learn ještě z tý
dopravníkový sítě,
kde ta komunikace si myslím, že fungovala.
Jenom bych byl rád,
kdyby byla rychlejší z naší strany,
tím myslím ne na tebe davide,
takže my už teďka od jedoteku
připravujeme kompletní plán ve smyslu
celýho layoutu, co kdy,
kdy se bude dělat jaký části stavebního
omezení potřebujem aplikovat a do toho
rozplánování nějakých těch očekávaných
výpadků teďka na tý dopravníkový síti,
a to se ti omlouvám teda ještě 1 davide.
Jsme to řešili tak trošku jako vždycky,
ad hoc, že jsme přišli a řekli,
hele za tejden potřebujem,
tak teď bych to chtěl mít trošku víc pod
palcem.
Po.
Super a teda to to o co se bude vytahovat
před věku, to bude řešit,
tak bude řešit Michal ceřin. Jo.
Potřebujete omezení?
Ano.
Super jo takhle s Davidem super.
Tak to bylo teda všechno a poslední téma,
teda robot.
Tak krobokvitku já krátce.
Tak 1 asi nejdůležitější zásadní věc z
dekantace.
Tam jsme teda oficiálně zahájili,
teda ten novej dekantační proces se
školením to má pod palcem primárně péťa
chapčáková se supportem Martina kiše,
tam to běží od minulého týdne.
Jestli si pamatuju správně tuším od
úterka, myslím se to oficiálně zahájilo.
Máme teda sepsaný kompletní nějakej
zadávací dokument dekantačního protokolu,
kterej se školí a podle kterýho to teďka
řekněme hlídáme, takže to je rozjeté,
to je za mě ta největší alfa omega,
která by nám měla z nějakých jako 70 80%.
Řešit val valnou většinu problémů,
který za rado pickem máme. Očekávám tedy,
že přibližně v horizontu 1 měsíce bychom
měli vidět 1 jako značný dopady a podle
obrátkovosti zboží si myslím,
že bysme ještě před sezonou už to jako
měli stabilizovat a mít to jako kompletně
pod palcem.
To teďka říkám na rovinu je takovej spíš
jako profesní odhad.
S reporting.
Obecně vlastně tady k těm totikům se
ještě maká na 1 toolu,
respektive kompletně jako aplikaci.
To je primárně teďka práce Martina kiše a
Tomáše vandase.
Kluci mají připravenou appku,
kde sledujeme reporting s vlastně podle
piku, co kdy, kde se děje, co bylo špatně,
jaký byly chyby,
jaká je vysoká ta chybovost a pro nás je
to teďka vlastně ta hlavní jako alfa
omega,
která bude hlavně pro kubu lázničku.
Aby sledoval tu chybovost a pomáhal nám
verifikovat ty zboží,
který by měli neměli bejt pickble,
řekněme,
jako je to nějakej ten hlavní jako tool
jo. Tam ještě se na tom pracuje,
ještě tam budou nějaký další updaty tady,
když teďka jako Martin říká změna
některých parametrů, nevím přesně jaký,
ale maká se na tom.
Tady ty ostatní jako detaily já asi jako
přeskočím. Myslím,
že to je svým způsobem jako daný jo ghost
picking máme tam prostě obecně nějaký
jako bugy nebo ještě detaily,
co se s reactem jako ladíme.
Přidám mobilní stolek, no dobře.
Drobné provozní úpravy v ročníku a ty
komfortu,
no to sou tady jako věci jako na place,
co se tam jako tady řeší, to je asi tady.
Nemusím tak rozemírat.
Teďka co se týče toho obecního plánu.
Máme teda rozjedané nějaké jako Martin,
říká storky nějaký jako topky na krájení
se na rku na ká jedničce se ještě teda
stále aplikuje ta příjmová apka,
nebo respektive aktualizace ty příjmový
apky, kde má bejt nějaká infografika,
nějaký instrukce k tomu,
že zboží robot pickebl?
Je to nějaká snaha pro toho operátora mu
trošku jako pomoci identifikovat to zboží
a jak ho jako handlovat to nasazení
vlastně mělo probíhat minulý týden,
ale nějak se to jako nepodařilo,
takže se to jako vrací vrací zpátky.
Plus nás tam ještě čeká,
teda ta finální jako apičková integrace,
jako by skenu do sereactu ale není to asi
teďka úplně to nejpalčivější téma u
reorke to máme vlastně to samý tam z tý z
těch 2 storek ta nejzásadnější teďka,
co je v paulovo frontě, je změna logiky.
Když žádáme o novej zdrojovej bin,
aby si ho žádal robot,
je to teda vlastně řekněme taková
virtuální simulace toho,
když operátor mačká zelené tlačítko?
A tady očekáváme,
že by ten pik to mělo docela drasticky
zrychlit cca u nějakých jako 15 20%.
Když se budeme držet při země.
A bude se teda obecně dál pracovat na
těch předchozích bodech,
ať už je to selekce těch prefixů segmentu,
což jsou výsledky teda z tý aplikace,
kde verifikujeme zboží, tak.
IS tou IS tou dekantací a budem stále
pokračovat dále na tom předávání k tomu
směrem k tomu provozu. Myslím si,
že v horizontu nějakých těch příštích
tejdnů řekněme obecně ke konci června
bysme mohli bejt podle mě v tý fázi,
kdy můžeme jít jako s tím,
že to oficiálně jako předáme plnohodnotně
jako pod provoz a pod tu tržbu ten
projekt.
Jako takovej.
5 krát.
Pod.
Takže když se tam kdykoliv přijdem
podělat v průběhu dne,
v průběhu pracovního týdne, tak ne,
tak ty roky pojedou.
Ano.
Kdy to můžeme spustit? 24.
Servery o víkendu?
Tam teďka máme ještě nějaký 2 ty bugy u
toho se reactu 100 se nám úplně jako
nelíbí.
V rámci toho abysme to provozovali
odpoledne v noci.
Týká se to teda těch costpiků a týká se
to teďka nějakýho poměrně častýho erodu u
1 robota s gripperem.
My jsme se s Martinem shodli,
že to ještě necháme bejt na nějakej
tejden 2 možná na ten den a.
Pak předáme nějaké to doporučení do
provozu, že za nás,
jako je ta situace je stabilizovaná ve
smyslu. Pokud se dějou problémy,
tak víme jaký a umíme všechny řešit a
pojedeme odpoledne večer teďka do tý doby,
dokud máme ten sedák,
ti support a jsme ještě stále tento
tejden v tom hypercare tak chceme
nechávat ten provoz přes den.
Já jsem si o tom psal s vláďou machem a
říkal jsem,
že potom Martin by měl být ta správná
osoba, která si definuje.
Hele za mě je to stabilní klidně už jako
provozujte odpoledne.
AV noci.
Jo, jestli ten teďka, to je stoproe kvůli.
Sere jako ne kvůli jako národní.
Tak tak tak.
Samozřejmě jako ten provoz tam taky má
ještě svoje slovo si říct, ano,
my se cítím jako dost proškolený a dost
důvěryhodný úč tomu robotovi a jdem do
toho jako na odpoledne noc.
To už pak nechám na ně.
Takže to.
Dobře, tak jo, otevření nevím někdy.
Tolik.
Tak jo, děkuju.
Jsem měsíční review měsíc review.
3 6 takže takže standardní rekapitulace
května měsíce května.
A poprosím samozřejmě milníky na červen.
Co vás čeká významného datum a na červen
radost z toho vytisknu a vydat víra pak
chce vylepit před kanceláří,
takže poprosím o ty milníky.
Co se týká stresté spolu dejme,
naplánujeme ho na to 18. 6 generál.
Je to děs.
Ano.
Skutečně po výplatný termín to dneska
pošlu.
Tak prosím počítejte všichni koho se to
týká 18 6 stres test.
Myslím, že co se týká nějakejch novinek,
tak tam teoreticky filipe už možná budeme
moct zkusit ty dopravníky.
Osmnáctýho 6 filipe.
Jo pardon,
já jsem o nutný hele asi bych ti to spíš
řekl zejtra nebo pozítří,
jak dopadne diskuze STMS.
A uvidíme.
Uvidíme každopádně vlastně na autostonu
ještě moc změnit nebude.
Já mám to studovat,
ještě moc mě nebude příjem právě proto,
že ten kine.
Sortování taky ne možná nějakýho pasu
zase.
Jo, takže se na to připravte,
co budete potřebovat?
Tak ať jste připravený na to,
že tam 18 6 teda ten stres to bude.
Myslím,
že davide je teďka někdy 2 tejdny zpátky
nebo minulej tejden jste?
Jste lízali 200, nebo jste překročili 200?
Takže si myslím,
že v tom červnu to bude jako velmi
podobný.
Takže ten výkon bude relativně jako pěkný.
No dobřekujeme se za tejden onsít, jo?
Potkáme se všichni osobně,
máme galerii husit nebo něco black nebo
něco mám velkou sedačku.
Tak jo díky čau.
Děkujeme.
Tak jo díky.
Ahoj.
Tak jo.
Díky ahoj.
Někdy?
Ahoj.
A.